اللياقة البدنية نعلم جميعًا أن هذا أمر
مهم ولكن غالبًا ما يتم التغاضي عنه هو
ما تعتبره لياقة اجتماعية ،
ما هو
الاكتشاف في بحثنا أن
الأشخاص الذين يبذلون قصارى جهدهم والذين هم الأكثر سعادة
وصحة يحافظون على
علاقاتهم التي ينشطون في
مواكبةها  علاقاتهم مع الحفاظ على الاتصال
بالأصدقاء والعائلة وأفراد المجتمع ،
أنت تقول إن الأشخاص الذين يبلغون من العمر 50 عامًا
يتمتعون بصلابة في علاقاتهم
سيكونون الأشخاص في سن الثمانين والذين يتمتعون
بصحة جيدة جسديًا وذهنيًا على حد سواء ،
لقد فات الأوان بالنسبة للبعض  الأشخاص الذين
يشاهدون الآن من قد يكون أكبر سنًا ، فات الأوان
لاتباع الوصفة الطبية الخاصة بك ،
لم يفت الأوان أبدًا بعد أن تبين لنا دراستنا
أن الأشخاص يجدون أصدقاء يجدون الحب
عندما يكونون متأكدين من أنه لن
يحدث لهم أبدًا في جميع النقاط المختلفة
من حياتهم.  يعيش ويعتمد الكثير على
ما إذا كنت تتعمد إقامة
علاقات جيدة ورعايتها
مجموعتك الأصلية على كلا جانبي
الدراسة أه أيها الرجال البيض ،
ما مدى موثوقية نتائجك للأشخاص
الذين ليسوا رجالًا بيضًا
جيدًا الآن لدينا توازن بين الجنسين لذلك قمنا
بإحضار  أزواج أحضرنا
أطفالًا أكثر من نصفهم من
النساء ، لذلك لدينا توازن بين الجنسين وما
نفعله هو التأكد من
تكرار نتائجنا من خلال دراسات أخرى
لأشخاص غير بيض ومن قبل أشخاص في جميع أنحاء
العالم لذلك نحن  نحن واثقون من أن
هذه النتائج صحيحة بالنسبة للأشخاص من
جميع الخلفيات التي كنت أستخدمها
في برنامجي الإذاعي
والمتصلين بعد مغادرتك ، فأشاروا إلى
نقصي في عدم السؤال عن الحيوانات الأليفة
وعدم السؤال عن الدين ، فقم بالتعامل مع كل
من هؤلاء الآن
لم ندرس الحيوانات الأليفة ولكن هناك  هي
دراسات تخبرنا أن لمسة
حيوان أليف يداعب حيوانًا أليفًا يقلل في الواقع من
معدل ضربات القلب ويهدئنا ، وله فائدة صحية
بهذه الطريقة مع الدين ، ما وجدناه
هو أن المتدينين لم يكونوا
أكثر سعادة من غير المتدينين وأنهم لم
يكونوا "  أقل سعادة ولكن
المتدينين والأشخاص الذين لديهم
ممارسات روحية قالوا إنهم وجدوا
هذه الممارسات راحة حقيقية في أوقات
التوتر